foreign
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we're the
minimalists we are here on this special
day malabama is here hi everybody and of
course the birthday boy TK Coleman We
Wish You a Merry Christmas
ah happy birthday TK to celebrate on
this free public minimal episode we're
bringing Dr Jerry Tennant on the show to
speak to a listener about chronic
illness if you or anyone you know is
suffering from a chronic illness then
this episode is for you please share it
widely with anyone who might be
suffering but please note none of this
is medical advice we don't give advice
on this podcast in this episode there's
certainly no exception we also have an
outstanding lightning round for you a
live stream question and a listener tip
oh you can check out the full two our
maximal edition of episode 368 with Dr
Jerry Tennant where we answer four times
the questions and we dive deep into
several simple living segments that
private podcast episode is out right now
at patreon.com the minimalists your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free because say with me
y'all
let's start with our callers if you have
a question or comment for our show give
us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists.com our first
question of the day is from Rand
this is Ryan from Houston Texas I know
that there are many causes of chronic
illness for example losing the genetic
Lottery
however there are many chronic lifestyle
illnesses diabetes heart disease and
cancer
do you think that there will ever be a
time when medicine will focus on
prevention instead of just treating the
symptoms
joining us by phone to help answer this
question is Dr Jerry Tennant MD he wrote
this book I'll hold it up if you're
watching the video version of the
podcast this book is called healing is
voltage and I the reason I wanted to
have Dr Tennant on the podcast I read
this book when I was doing something
called pemf therapy and this book was in
the waiting room and I immediately
picked it up and started going through
it and I realized oh I know a lot but
there's so much I don't know about my
own chronic illness that I've been
dealing with the last four years and
this really helped put it in perspective
for me Dr Tena thank you so much for
joining us today
well thank you for having me you know I
want to address rand's question head on
and then we'll dive a bit into your book
as well now we all know that a a thimble
of prevention is more effective than a
truckload of treatment and so the best
way to deal with any sort of chronic
illness is to prevent it before it
happens and I think you talk about that
quite a bit in your book but then also
when someone is suffering from some sort
of chronic illness whether it's an
autoimmune disease or cancer or
something else that is plaguing their
life
Well they um
their whole life tends to to change and
what Rand is is talking about here is a
paradigm shift and you talk about this
paradigm shift in your book as well I
was hoping maybe you could talk to Rand
about when do we make this shift because
medicine is really great at treating
acute illnesses if I sprain my ankle or
break my leg great I can go to the
hospital I can get a cast it can really
help me but beyond that we're we're at a
loss for healing today in fact it seems
that we are sicker than ever yeah so
Rand I appreciate your uh question and
uh wish that we had the rest of the week
to answer it uh because there are
um
many
um
misconceptions
that have been taught to Physicians and
to the public for many years and your
question included uh several of those
and so I'm going to with uh try to keep
my answer as short as possible but still
give you some information if I may yes
please
first of all
the idea that you got a shaft on the
genetic Lottery is primarily incorrect
so uh the the idea that our genes are in
control of everything
um actually was proven back uh to be
incorrect back in the 1950s a chap got a
Nobel Prize for showing that our genes
uh that we get from our parents uh
change where uh and they change not only
according to
um
to our environment but according to our
diet
um
and so uh we we do have uh the genes our
parents gave us but if you look at genes
from twins say when they're born and
then you look at them again say when
they're 20 they're the same when they're
born they're different when they're 20.
um
so we're not stuck with the with the uh
genetic programming that our parents
have passed on to us uh with perhaps the
exception of genetic emotions which is a
whole other subject unto itself uh which
I wish we had time to discuss but let me
move on
so
um
it was shown uh some time ago then that
our genes change
and that actually even our diet changes
so for example
um a group took mice that are called
agouti agouta agati mice
which are are fat and yellow
and they gave them a diet that was
filled with uh appropriate methylation
and now all their kids and all their
grandkids and all the great grandkids
were small normal and brown and so they
changed the genetic presentation of all
their offspring by just fixing the
methylation defect that came along with
the epigenetics uh and not necessarily
the genetics itself
so that's one misconception
another one for example was you
mentioned cancer
so uh in the early 1900s about 1910 if
my memory serves me
a chapter named Bovary suggested that
cancer occurs when our genes mutate and
cause cells to grow rapidly into tumors
and so the theory that's still being
taught and still being used in treating
malignancies is based on bovary's
suggestion which was proven in two in um
in 2013 to be incorrect so for a hundred
years we've been using the wrong Theory
to treat cancer
so what uh what Thomas Seyfried in
Boston at Boston University did excuse
me was to
take a cell that uh was malignant and
its nucleus had mutated genes he removed
that nucleus with its mutated genes and
inserted a normal nucleus assuming the
cell would now become normal it did not
it stayed malignant he then did the
opposite he took a normal cell removed
its nucleus and put in a nucleus that
had mutated genes assuming the cell
would become malignant it did not it
stayed normal wow so after that was
repeated at several other universities
it became obvious that mutated genes
aren't what's driving the bus
and uh though they're simply a secondary
phenomenon
and so when you realize that uh
that our therapies for example for for
example uh it's been shown by the
Australians that
that people who do chemotherapy
um
uh
2.3 percent of them live longer than
those who don't uh in the uh us and 2.1
percent in Australia so 90 basically 98
of people who do chemotherapy it's
ineffective I noticed some staggering
stats in in your book about cancer
treatments in general and that was
certainly one of them
so the issue again it's not genetically
driven
now you know I could spend obviously if
I had another 10 or 15 minutes to talk
to you just about cancer I could tell
you what I think is the cause and how
how it works but then uh that would take
up our whole time so but basically what
I want you to take away hopefully from
what I'm telling you is to spend a
little more time doing research and do
not believe that you're stuck with the
results of the genetic quote genetic
Lottery that you can change your genetic
function by changing not only your your
diet but changing your about your vision
of the environment in which you live and
that all chronic disease starts and ends
with whether or not cells lose their
voltage which causes them to lose oxygen
and then everything is downhill from
there so hopefully we'll have time to
discuss that a little bit later so I
hope that answer is helpful to you Jerry
I think that's a perfect way to segue
into your book we tend to do the segment
on the podcast called more about less
and we used to do it on the private
podcast I'm going to pull it up here
because I thought this was a perfect
time to dive into your book and so I've
got some excerpts here I've I'm I treat
this book almost like an encyclopedia in
a way and this will feel like a bit of a
deep dive but I assure you we are only
scratching the surface I couldn't go
through even 10 of this book right now
but I wanted to start on page 24 because
it really starts with your story Jerry
and you were a surgeon and in 1994 in
the book you talk about how you
developed through actually doing eye
surgeries on people you developed
Encephalitis neuropathies and a low
platelet count and other nervous system
defects in 1994. you said in the book I
could see a patient to diagnose what was
wrong with them but I couldn't remember
how to write a prescription I also
developed [ __ ] movements that
prevented me from safely performing eye
surgery I had to quit work on November
30th 1995 for almost seven years I slept
about 16 hours per day
remember that I had viruses and my brain
and viruses in my spleen and in your
book there is this really cute picture
of you sleeping with uh you have two
dogs who are sort of sharing their
electrons with you which is really
opening the door for I think maybe even
the third chapter of the book which is
called healing is voltage the book is
called that but also the third chapter
there you're talking about voltage so
what was the impetus here obviously you
had a tremendous tremendous problem with
your own health right but uh that that
opened up the door for you to discover
ways to heal
exactly so I was doing the research for
the laser uh made by the company called
visex that's used in LASIK surgery I did
about 90 of that research and I had a
lot of fun doing it but we didn't know
at the time that the laser wouldn't kill
viruses
and so I was using it actually on a man
from India who had scars in The
Superficial part of his cornea to carve
those scars off
and um so at the time we didn't know
that the laser wouldn't kill viruses so
it released the viruses from his
leukemia that caused his corneal
scarring and those came up went through
my mask through my nose and into my
brain and I developed Encephalitis and
so what as you pointed out it resulted
in the fact that I could still figure
out what was wrong with the patient but
I couldn't figure out how to treat them
or remember how to do it plus when I was
doing cataract surgery which I did a
great deal of
um all of a sudden I would develop a
[ __ ] movement uh and almost jump out
of my chair which doesn't work really
well if you're operating inside
somebody's eyeball
and so
um in order to be sure that I never
harmed anybody I realized I had to quit
and so I never did hurt anybody I I
never did happen to me during a surgical
procedure but I'm sure it would have a
headache continued on sure and so
um
and so uh I went to the to the best
doctors I could find and I went to the
head of Cornell Immunology at Harvard in
Boston I went to the head of the NIH
division of infectious disease and they
said well you got three viruses in your
brain we don't know what to do about it
so don't call us we'll call you
and so I had two or three hours a day in
which I could understand a newspaper or
something similar and they like a light
switch it'd go off and I couldn't
understand it anymore
so I realized I had a choice to make I
could use those two or three hours a day
to try to figure out how to get myself
well or I could just lay down and die
and I chose the former
and so I began the process of trying to
figure out how to get myself well
and so as I was sitting in my lazy chair
um
the thought came to me that if I could
figure out how to make one cell work I
could make them all work because even
though they look different sort of like
a a desktop computer looks different
from a uh from say an iPad they're
basically the same they have all the
same Parts they just look different and
have different software and so it is
with the human cells they look different
and have different software
so I thought well huh if I can figure
out how to make one of these work I can
make them all work and so I started down
that road and so I bought a bunch of
of cellular biology books which I hadn't
read in about 30 years
and as I was reading through each one of
them something jumped out at me each one
of them had a either a sentence or a
page devoted to the fact that cells have
to run at a pH of 7.35 to 7.45 well I
didn't remember much about pH so I
started reading about that and
discovered that pH is simply measurement
of voltage in a liquid as compared to
voltage in a wire
so if you've got a copper wire you turn
the switch on electrons are moving turn
the switch off they stop but in a liquid
the liquid can either be an electron
donor or an electron stealer
and so you use what's called a pH meter
which is a fancy voltmeter designed for
measuring voltage in a liquid and it has
a switch on it so you put in one
position and it will tell you the pH of
the of the liquid you switch it to the
other direction and it gives you the
synonym which is a measurement in
millivolts
so I said huh
cells have to have voltage to work gosh
that makes sense uh and so how do I
measure it
and so that's how I got started down
this path I can continue the story if
you like but that was sort of the
Genesis of my realizing that I needed
voltage and as I was able to get the
rudimentary equipment to measure it I
found my brain was running between two
and four millivolts instead of the 25
millivolts where it's designed to work
and so that started my journey that I'm
still on
well let me ask you this so in in the
book on page 91 you say you will hear
statements such as all disease occurs
when you are acidic what this really is
saying is that all disease occurs when
your voltage is low or an electron
electronic Steeler state so can we talk
about that real quick what do you mean
by when your voltage is low
so uh Physicians and other people
working in Health Sciences are taught
that there is such a thing as voltage in
the body because we measure it with an
electrocardiogram for the heart or an
electroencephalogram for the brain but
but for some reason physiologists and
Physicians think that there's really not
such a thing as voltage in all of our
other cells which doesn't make any sense
of course
uh because they all have voltage
and so
the other thing that we're taught is
that inside the cell we have a molecule
called ATP which is the electron donor
that makes the cell work but that's just
one of the eight batteries that the body
actually has our H our body has eight
different batteries and uh
had the and a a sophisticated electronic
wiring system so the human body is
actually an electronic device and like
all other electronic portable electronic
devices it has to have a battery system
to work and so we have these batteries
and interestingly enough
the largest batteries we have are our
muscles
now our muscles are piezoelectric so
what does that funny word mean
so
if you are if you distort something and
it emits electrons that's called
piezoelectricity
so for example if you take a piece of
quartz and you squeeze it with a pair of
pliers it emits electrons and that's
basically by the way how quartz watches
work
but our muscles are also rechargeable
batteries
and so our muscles are stacked one on
top of each other in a very specific
order like stuck and batteries in a
flashlight
to form a power pack and so every organ
in the body has its own muscle battery
pack
and a stack of muscle batteries what's
been called an acupuncture Meridian and
it's surrounded by this shiny stuff
called fascia
so when you carve your Thanksgiving
turkey you'll see that around the
muscles are this shiny sheath of things
and that is that is that birds wiring
system as it is yours and that wiring
system is actually in in electronics
what's called a semiconductor which
means it moves electrons very very
rapidly but only in One Direction
so what we find then is that every organ
gets its 25 millivolts to run from that
acupuncture muscle battery pack
and that but to make new cells when
cells wear out or get injured you have
to have double that 50 millivolts
and so what you find is that anytime you
have a chronic disease that that battery
pack has failed you that that
acupuncture circuit muscle battery pack
has failed you and what do I mean by
that
it's well known in Battery Technology
that if you take a rechargeable battery
and you drain it all the way to zero it
flips itself upside down polarity wise
so if you think about a battery it has a
Plus on one end and a minus on the other
if you drain it to zero the plus and
minus switch places now if you put it in
a battery charger upside down like that
it won't take a charge well it
so all chronic disease of any
consequence you will find that the the
battery pack in that circuit has flipped
its polarity upside down
you it's it's basically in my opinion
for example you can't have any
significant chronic disease unless you
flip the polarity in its battery pack
let me say that one more time because
how this is amazingly powerful you
cannot have
any significant chronic disease unless
you have flipped propolarity in that
organs battery pack what you say in the
book is that all chronic disease is
always defined by having low voltage and
I found this line really powerful he
said you can take all the medications
you like and do as much surgery as you
like but you will not heal unless you
have negative 50 millivolts raw
materials and a lack of toxins and I
think what's important to note here is
it's not to say that all prescriptions
or all medications are inherently bad or
surgery is bad but understanding that
those things alone don't allow us to
heal in fact they often will cover up
the healing the analogy you use in the
book is if you have a wooden plank that
is Infested by termites simply painting
the wooden plank isn't going to fix the
termite problem and I think that's what
we're talking about Dr Tennant we're
talking about chronic illness is
fundamentally there is an issue with the
voltage in our bodies so where do we go
knowing that and you in the book we'll
actually pivot here in a second to
nutrition because I think that's a a big
part of it but knowing that well where
where do we go if someone's suffering
with some debilitating chronic illness
whether it's an autoimmune disease or
something else what um what do we tell
them other than hey you don't have
enough voltage
well I've spent the last 25 years trying
to teach people how to measure it so
they can know if their circuits are on
or off and then what to do about it and
what caused it and we've identified five
different things that cause you to flip
the polarity not a thyroid hormone
so without the thyroid hormone T3 not T4
but T3 controls the voltage of every
cell membrane in the body and the total
number of mitochondria in the body so
you got to be sure to get that right
if you put a scar across your wiring
system a scar or Tattoo You frayed the
wire and so even if the battery inside
that stocking of wire is has charged up
it can't go anyplace because there's got
a screwed up wiring system so you got to
fix your scars
uh next is Dental infections
so when an embryo is is being is forming
it forms the brain first and then
circuits go from the brain down into the
rest of the body and on their way into
the body they go through very specific
teeth
so if you get a short or a corrosion
around a tooth by that I mean let's say
you have a dead tooth like a root canal
tooth or you get infection in the bone
around a tooth it shorts the circuit out
and so uh the so then Dental infections
are a very common reason that people get
chronically ill
and then we have emotions emotions are
stored in the body as magnetic fields
and if you put a magnetic field around a
circuit it blocks the flow of electrons
doesn't it so our emotions do that and
we figured out by the way how to convert
emotions into being just memories using
physics and electronics
and then finally we have toxins and
under toxins of course you have The
Usual Suspects you know pesticides and
and infections and all the other toxins
that around us so
so you have when when you have enough of
any of those five things to add up to
drain your battery to zero it flips it
and when it flips it now you're gonna
get sick and nothing you can do will
allow you to get well until you can flip
that battery back up that way it's
polarity back up with a with what's
called scalar energy
which will do it and then you recharge
it with electromagnetic energy and now
once your battery's charged back up the
body gets busy and heals itself because
the body never forgets how to heal just
has to have the foliage and the
nutrition and get rid of the toxins to
do it
wow and that's what I teach yeah this is
uh wow this is so fascinating I'm
interested Dr Tennant in you know you
made this discovery about yourself so
what things did you start to do to um
get on your road to Healing
well obviously the the first step is you
got to know where you're going uh you
know
I've told my kids as they were growing
up you know you gotta have a goal uh of
where you're going with your life or
you'll never get there and even if you
choose the wrong direction you can
always change but have a goal and so it
is with this you've got to know what
you're what you're dealing with and so
as I mentioned earlier I've discovered
that there's only one road one Pathway
to all chronic disease
and so no matter what you're dealing
with whether
you know whether you've got arthritis
whether you've got heart that won't work
whether you've got breast cancer or
whether you've got
um ALS Lou Gehrig's Disease whether
you've got scoliosis whether you've got
macular degeneration in your eyes the
list goes on and on they all you got
there with all of them the same exact
way and that is
you flip the polarity in this power
supply
and so when you do that you lose the
ability to deliver oxygen to that
particular organ
anytime in all living things plants and
animals contain fungal spores and when
the fungal the the reason we have fungus
on the planet
is to take dead ordine organic material
and turn it to dirt
so for example
uh when a leaf falls off a tree there
are fungal spores on it and when that
leaf no longer has voltage and oxygen
the fungal spores wake up and it's it's
their job to turn that leaf to dirt well
the same thing happens if you lose
voltage and oxygen in your breast or
your prostate or your liver whatever
uh the fungal spores wake up and try to
turn that organ to dirt because that's
what their job is
and then there is this stimulus uh when
you lose oxygen to uh to have uh stem
cells go nearby and invade nearby blood
vessels and make a mass to bring in more
oxygen and so that's where we end up so
the point is that that no matter what's
wrong with you
uh it always goes down this same pathway
and anything else you do
short of pushing it back to where you
have normal voltage and normal oxygen is
simply a Band-Aid and it buys you some
perhaps not you don't feel so bad while
you're in the process of going down the
tubes but it's easy once you start
understanding things and looking at the
body Through The Eyes of physics instead
of Through The Eyes of biochemistry it's
much easier to deal with all of these
so-called untreatable illnesses and I'm
a perfect example of that you know I was
supposed to diet and
at the end of the
uh you know of the 1990s and here I am
25 years later still trekking yeah
Jerry in the book you you talk about
quite a few things I won't have time to
cover here things like why most people
are iodine deficient uh why it makes
sense to get off antacids and drugs that
stop the production of stomach acid and
why a lack of stomach acid might
actually cause obesity you talk about
metabolic syndrome X and fibromyalgia
and hypothyroidism talk about the
dangers of Stratton or statin drugs you
talk about why most people have been
exposed to Lyme disease but only some
people have the symptoms of Lyme disease
and there's a whole lot more in the book
bowling ball syndrome was something that
was really fascinating to me that uh
unfortunately won't have time to cover
but you can check that out of the book I
do want to spend some time real quick
though on chapter five you talk about
nutrition and you say the key to making
chronic disease better is making a
single cell work if you give the body
the things a single cell needs to work
the body often has the power to heal all
of the cells of the body and that means
you get well and then later in the
chapter you say to be healthy you must
stop eating anything that says partially
hydrogenated or canola oil
so we can talk about the problems with
seed oils here you have to stop eating
fried foods and cheese and restaurants
because these almost always are made of
partially hydrogenated seed oils in
addition you must stop using all forms
of artificial sweeteners such as
aspartame Splenda Xylitol and other
sweeteners that end in ol in fact I
stopped chewing the regular gum that I
used to chew every day most of the day
after reading that paragraph and you say
all of these are severe neurotoxins that
the body doesn't know how to get rid of
stop MSG as it is also in neurotoxin
stop smoking that should be obvious stop
eating soy and now
Jerry we got to talk about this one stop
drinking coffee are you saying I have to
put down this coffee that's in front of
me right now oh no it's the one my one
Vice in life
well you know the
if you if you stop and think about
everything that you put into your body
is this an electron donor or an electron
stealer
then you will have some guidance
um
and if you look for example I've read a
lot of the cancer literature for example
and everything that I can find that's
ever been reported that has made cancer
better is an electron donor everything
that I can find that people report well
this causes cancer is an electron
stealer
and so once you start thinking in terms
of electron donor electron stealer your
life becomes much simpler and as you
might guess people come to me all the
time and you know hey Dr Tanner would
you will you recommend this product or
will you do this or whatever and I look
at it and I see you know
what's the what's the balance of
electron donors and electron Steelers in
it and then I can have a better idea and
so
you know I coffee has its own set of
problems it is an electron stealer and
it and it blocks the absorption of all
the good minerals
[Music]
yeah just basically all your good
minerals get blocked the absorption gets
blocked and it's also an electron
stealer now if you're doing other things
you're you're monitoring the polarity of
your acupuncture circuits which I tried
to teach my patients how to do and it's
online and it's an easy thing to do
it's uh like a you know a pilot goes
around his airplane and checks to be
sure that the gas tanks are full and
that you know all the hinges work and so
forth you could you can do the same
thing every day you brush your teeth and
then you check your polarities and make
sure that all your switches are on and
then you go off to work if you find to
switch it off fix it so if you find then
that that
how you just love coffee but your
switches are staying on
and you're doing all the other good
things most of what you're putting in
your body is an electron donor okay have
your coffee
Ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it's time for the lightning round
where we answer your questions from
social media yes indeed you can follow
the minimalists on Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook and Twitter at the minimalist
during the lightning round we each have
60 seconds to answer questions with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maximus in the show notes over
at the minimalists.com podcast so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like you can find
all of our minimal maxims over there in
the show notes we have a question from
Nadine on Facebook how can minimalism be
used as a tool to assist the prevention
and management of chronic illness okay
so today on the private podcast we spoke
with Dr Jerry Tennant about chronic
illness we dove into his book some of
that on the public version as well go
ahead and throw 60 seconds on the clock
for me because I want to unpack this was
something pithy
if addition is the calls subtraction is
the cure too often what we're trying to
do to
prevent or cure chronic illness or to
prevent or cure chronic staphitis the
material possessions in our homes
is add more you know what will solve my
problem with stuff if I just go to The
Container Store and get a bunch of bins
I buy things to fix my problem with
things and we do the same thing with our
medical problems as well if I were to
just get more medication or more
treatment or more doctor's visits more
more more is actually the cause of the
dis-ease so subtraction is the real cure
hmm I love it all right all right
Professor Sean give me 60 seconds
um my pithy answer is this
more consumption more problems or you
could say mo consumption Mo Problems
but here's the thing is that when we
consume more we're bringing uh we're
bringing more things into our life
whether it's physical clutter or whether
it's uh bad food whatever it is if we're
consuming more food we're consuming more
physical items if we're consuming more
entertainment
we are going to have more problems we we
have to be able to set up these
boundaries so we can avoid things like
you know chronic illness so and then
prevent things like that but also you're
preventing a cluttered mind you're
preventing a cluttered home
um so yeah I mean it's it's uh it sounds
so simple and it is simple but uh but we
all know Sublime Ain't Easy
yeah
ladies and gentlemen TK Coleman's got 60
seconds Enlighten us
minimalism
maximizes the value of everything Dr
John deloney uses the metaphor of
walking around with a backpack full of
bricks to capture the idea of the things
that weigh us down if you're walking
around with a backpack full of bricks no
matter what you do go for a walk go for
a bike ride go for a hike sit down to
have dinner you are going to be
unnecessarily weighed down you're going
to be heavier but when you start taking
bricks out of that backpack you are
lighter you are Freer and no matter what
you do you bring that lightness and that
freedom to the activity we can't tell
you how to be you that knowledge comes
from within what we can help you with is
the Art of Letting Go of the things that
unnecessarily hold you back from being
who you already know to be minimalism
can make every aspect of your life
better because it's about letting go of
those things that keep you from being
the best version of yourself you already
know how to be yes
I mean technically he was half a second
over but
we'll clean it up and post yeah we're
gonna check in with our patreon live
stream here in a moment but first real
quick for right here right now a little
segment we do where we talk about one
thing that's going on in the life of the
minimalists it's TK's favorite time of
year not only is today the day we're
recording this his birthday but it is
Christmas time It's the Most Wonderful
Time of the Year hey y'all I wrote an
anti-horror story on Facebook what um
you gotta let me read this maybe we
don't have time today and maybe we'll
come back next week but I got a little
anti-horr story that I wrote for all of
the people who are like you can't play
that Christmas music until after
Thanksgiving uh I think you all will
like it I think you'll enjoy it all
right I'm looking forward to that for
speaking of Christmas TK we have as you
know the minimalist rule book 16 rules
for living with less which you can
download for free over the
minimalists.com and in there two of
those 16 rules are about gift giving we
have a gift giving rule that we call it
the minimalist gift-giving rule I won't
spoil it you'll have to download the
free ebook in order to read that but
then we also have the minimalist gift
getting rule oh and as minimalist we
still accept gifts and we talk about
both of those rules in the minimalist
rule book If you're looking for other
Christmas related materials on
minimalism check out our YouTube channel
if you just go to youtube.com the
minimalists and you type in Christmas
there on the little search bar there are
quite a few Christmas videos we have on
there so Ryan and I did three seasons of
this show called living room
conversations and one of those was
season two episode 17. what's Christmas
morning like in a minimalist home little
episode that he and I did together
there's another episode over there
called can we talk about all these
stupid Christmas gifts
and then another one a question that we
had was how do you get people to stop
buying you gifts you'll find a whole lot
more of that a bunch of free materials
over there about Christmas if you go to
youtube.com the minimalists and just
type in Christmas in the search bar
let's tune in to our patreon live stream
Alabama you got a question for us I sure
do we have a question here from Lisa she
wants to know if there are any insights
into the evolutionary reasons as to why
some individuals suffer from migraines
you know I started suffering from
migraines just this year and I during
our added value segment which we're
going to do on the the private podcast
this week I have something that's helped
out immensely with the headaches
um I found that there are multiple
factors in mind I went to go see our
um chiropractor uh Jamie montabon and Dr
Fantasia you know Fantasia's going out
on his own now no way either they're
breaking off the duel man dude they they
make the best team they really do uh
anyway they had me get this particular
neck pillow that I lay on like three
times a day for two minutes a day and
it's helped the migraine significantly
on a previous episode I talked about the
CO2 and maybe if you're breathing too
much CO2 that can lead to headaches as
well also overdoing it on any vitamins
or supplements can can cause headaches
oh
um sinuses are another reason that we
tend to get migraines if we have some
sort of sinus congestion and then in
this book healing is voltage there's the
whole chapter about bowling ball
syndrome which causes migraines so
you'll have to check that out uh one
thing that the chiropractors really
helped me out with is mine tends to be
this muscle right here when it gets real
tight if I'm sleeping on a fun the if I
lay on it funny
this muscle here causes migraines I feel
him when he like adjusts right here I
can feel it up here in my head oh wow so
those are all multiple factors
um migraines are just telling us it's a
sign it's the pain that ports points us
toward the healing as we talked about
earlier on the private podcast that pain
is pointing you toward a direction to go
so that you can heal all right before we
get to our listener tips today coming up
on the private podcast this week we have
a private minimalist home tour we have
our impulse purchases segment we of
course have TK's tweet of the week
we have an outstanding added value
segment for you and much more of less in
the meantime Alabama what do you got for
us here's a minimalist Insight from one
of our listeners
this is Rochelle from Saginaw Michigan I
just finished the subtract episode and I
have a suggestion for Kelly and anyone
who's trying to listen more
I have adopted the practice of adjusting
my posture when I realized that I'm in a
situation where I need to listen
for example if I'm seated I stack my
hands in my lap with my Palms up and
this reminds myself that I am here to
receive what the other person has to say
I hope this this tip helps Kelly and
anyone else trying to listen more things
all right y'all that's our minimal
episode for today big thanks to Dr Jerry
Tennant for joining us his book is
called healing is voltage I'll put a
link to this in the show notes by the
way TK we got a bunch more surprise
questions on the private podcast this
week like what can I do to improve my
self-care routine how do you let go of
addiction what is the minimalist new
junk drawer Challenge and how can you
use it to minimize all that clutter in
your junk drawer today y'all are gonna
love that one plus a million more
questions for the minimalists and Dr
tenant and if you want to hear all that
check out the minimalist private podcast
at patreon.com the minimalists or click
the link in the description if you leave
here today with just one message
but it'd be this
love people
and use things
[Music]
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it